i spent the past three years talking to
some of the worst people
on the internet now if you've been
online recently
you may have noticed that there's a lot
of toxic garbage out there
racist memes misogynist propaganda viral
misinformation
so i wanted to know who was making this
stuff i wanted to understand how they
were spreading it
ultimately i wanted to know what kind of
impact it might be having on our society
so
in 2016 i started tracing some of these
memes back to their source
back to the people who were making them
or who were making them go viral i'd
approach those people and say hey i'm a
journalist can i come watch you do what
you do
now often the response would be why in
hell would i want to talk to some low t
soy boy brooklyn globalist jew cuck
who's in cahoots with the democrat party
to which my response would be look man
that's only 57 percent true
but often i got the opposite response
yeah sure come on by
so that's how i ended up in the living
room of a social media propagandist
in southern california he was a married
white guy in his late 30s
he had a table in front of him with a
mug of coffee
a laptop for tweeting a phone for
texting
and an ipad for live streaming to
periscope and youtube
that was it and yet with those tools he
was able to propel his fringe
noxious talking points into the heart of
the american conversation
for example one of the days i was there
a bomb had just exploded in new york
and the guy accused of planting the bomb
had a muslim sounding name
now to the propagandist in california
this seemed like an opportunity
because one of the things he wanted was
for the u.s to cut off almost
all immigration especially from
muslim-majority countries
so he started live streaming getting his
followers worked up into a frenzy about
how the open borders agenda was going to
kill us all
and asking them to tweet about this and
use specific hashtags trying to get
those hashtags trending
and tweet they did hundreds and hundreds
of tweets
a lot of them featuring images like this
one so that's george soros he's a
hungarian billionaire and philanthropist
and in the minds of some conspiracists
online
george soros is like a globalist
boogeyman one of a few
elites who's secretly manipulating all
of global affairs now
just pause here if this idea sounds
familiar to you that there are a few
elites who control the world and
a lot of them happen to be rich jews
that's because it is one of the most
anti-semitic tropes in existence
i should also mention that the guy in
new york who planted that bomb
he was an american citizen so whatever
else was going on there immigration was
not the main issue
and the propagandist in california he
understood all this he was a well-read
guy he was actually a lawyer
he knew the underlying facts but he also
knew that facts do not drive
conversation online what drives
conversation online
is emotion see the original premise of
social media was that it was going to
bring us all together
make the world more open and tolerant
and fair and it did some of that
but the social media algorithms have
never been built to distinguish between
what's true or false
what's good or bad for society what's
pro-social and what's anti-social
that's just not what those algorithms do
a lot of what they do is measure
engagement
clicks comments shares retweets that
kind of thing
and if you want your content to get
engagement it has to spark
emotion specifically what behavioral
scientists call high arousal emotion
now high arousal doesn't only mean
sexual arousal although it's the
internet obviously that works
it means anything positive or negative
that gets people's hearts pumping
so i would sit with these propagandists
not just the guy in california but
dozens of them and i would watch
as they did this again and again
successfully
not because they were russian hackers
not because they were tech prodigies
not because they had unique political
insights just because they understood
how social media worked
and they were willing to exploit it to
their advantage now at first i was able
to tell myself this was a fringe
phenomenon
something that was relegated to the
internet but there's really no
separation anymore between the internet
and everything else this is an ad that
ran on multiple tv stations during the
2018 congressional elections
alleging with very little evidence that
one of the candidates was in the pocket
of international manipulator george
soros who's
awkwardly photoshopped here next to
stacks of cash
this is a tweet from the president of
the united states alleging again with no
evidence that
american politics is being manipulated
by george soros
this stuff that once seemed so shocking
and marginal and frankly just ignorable
it's now so normalized that we hardly
even notice it
so i spent about three years in this
world i talked to a lot of people
some of them seem to have no core
beliefs at all they just seem to be
betting
perfectly rationally that if they wanted
to make some money online or get some
attention online they should just be as
outrageous as possible
but i talked to other people who were
true ideologues
and to be clear their ideology was not
traditional conservatism right these
were people who wanted to
revoke female suffrage these are people
who wanted to go back to racial
segregation some of them wanted to do
away with democracy altogether
now obviously these people were not born
believing these things they didn't
pick them up in elementary school a lot
of them before they went down some
internet rabbit hole they had been
libertarian or they'd been socialist or
they'd been something else entirely so
what was going on well i can't
generalize about every case but
a lot of the people i spoke to they seem
to have a combination of a high iq and a
low eq
right they seem to take comfort in
anonymous online spaces rather than
connecting in the real world
so often they would retreat to these
message boards or these subreddits where
they
their worst impulses would be magnified
they might start out saying something
just as a sick joke
and then they would get so much positive
reinforcement for that joke so many
meaningless internet points as they
called it that they might start
believing their own joke
i talked a lot with one young woman who
grew up in new jersey
and then after high school she moved to
a new place and suddenly she just felt
alienated and cut off and
started retreating into her phone she
found some of these spaces on the
internet where people would post the
most shocking
heinous things and she found this stuff
really off-putting but also
kind of engrossing kind of like she
couldn't look away from it
she started interacting with people in
these online spaces and they made her
feel smart they made her feel validated
she started feeling a sense of community
started wondering if maybe some of these
shocking memes might actually contain a
kernel of truth
a few months later she was in a car with
some of her new internet friends
headed to charlottesville virginia to
march with torches in the name of the
white race
she'd gone in a few months from obama
supporter to fully radicalized white
supremacist
now in her particular case she actually
was able to find her way out
of the cult of white supremacy but a lot
of the people i spoke to were not
and just to be clear i was never so
convinced that i had to find common
ground with every single
person i spoke to that i was willing to
say you know what man
you're a fascist propagandist i'm not
whatever let's just hug it out
all our differences will melt away no
absolutely not
but i did become convinced that we
cannot just look away from this stuff
we have to try to understand it because
only by understanding it can we even
start
to inoculate ourselves against it
in my three years in this world i got a
few nasty phone calls even some threats
but it wasn't a fraction of what female
journalists get on this beat
and yeah i am jewish although weirdly a
lot of the nazis couldn't tell i was
jewish
which i frankly just found kind of
disappointing
seriously like your whole job is being a
professional anti-semite
nothing about me is tipping you off at
all nothing
this is not a secret my name is andrew
morantz i write for the new yorker
my personality type is like if a
seinfeld episode was taped at the park
slope food co-op
nothing
anyway look you know ultimately it would
be nice if there were like a simple
formula you know
smartphone plus alienated kid equals 12
chance of nazi
it's obviously not that simple and in my
writing
i'm much more comfortable being
descriptive not prescriptive
but this is ted so
let's get practical i want to share a
few suggestions of things that
citizens of the internet like you and i
might be able to do to make things a
little bit less toxic
so the first one is to be a smart
skeptic
so i think there are two kinds of
skepticism and i don't want to drown you
in technical epistemological tech
information here but i call them smart
and dumb skepticism
so smart skepticism thinking for
yourself
questioning every claim demanding
evidence great
that's real skepticism dumb skepticism
it sounds like skepticism but it's
actually closer to knee-jerk
contrarianism
everyone says the earth is round you say
it's flat everyone says racism is bad
you say
i don't know i'm skeptical about that i
cannot tell you how many young white men
i have spoken to
in the last few years who have said you
know the media my teachers they're all
trying to indoctrinate me into believing
in male privilege and white privilege
but i don't know about that man i don't
think so
guys contrarian white teens of the world
look if you are being a round earth
skeptic
and a male privileged skeptic and a
racism is bad skeptic
you're not being a skeptic you're being
a jerk
it's great to be independent-minded we
all should be independent-minded but
just
be smart about it so this next one's
about free speech so
you will hear smart accomplished people
who will say well i'm pro-free speech
right and they say it in this way that
it's like they're settling a debate
when actually that is the very beginning
of any meaningful conversation
all the interesting stuff happens after
that point okay you're pro free speech
what does that mean
does it mean that david duke and richard
spencer need to have active twitter
accounts
does it mean that anyone can harass
anyone else online for any reason
you know i look through the entire list
of ted speakers this year i didn't find
a single round earth skeptic
is that a violation of free speech norms
look we're all pro free speech it's
wonderful to be pro free speech but if
that's all you know how to say again and
again
you're standing in the way of a more
productive conversation
making decency cool again so
great yeah i don't even need to explain
it
i um so in my research i would go to
reddit or youtube or facebook and i
would search for sharia law
or i'd search for the holocaust and you
might be able to guess what the
algorithm showed me right
is sharia law sweeping across the united
states did the holocaust
really happen dumb skepticism
so we've ended up in this bizarre
dynamic online where some people see
bigoted propaganda as being edgy or
being dangerous and cool
and people see basic truth and human
decency as pearl clutching or virtue
signaling or just
boring and the social media algorithms
whether intentionally or not they have
incentivized this
because bigoted propaganda is great for
engagement
everyone clicks on it everyone comments
on it whether they love it or they hate
it
so the number one thing that has to
happen here is social networks need to
fix their platforms
so if you're listening to my voice and
you work at a social media company or
you invest in one or i don't know own
one
this tip is for you if you have been
optimizing for maximum emotional
engagement
and maximum emotional engagement turns
out to be actively harming the world
it's time to optimize for something else
but in addition to putting pressure on
them to do that and waiting for them and
hoping that they'll do that
there's some stuff that the rest of us
can do too so
we can create some better pathways or
suggest some better pathways for angsty
teens to go down
if you see something that you think is
really creative and thoughtful and you
want to share that thing
you can share that thing even if it's
not flooding you with high arousal
emotion
now that is a very small step i realize
but in the aggregate this stuff does
matter
because these algorithms as powerful as
they are they are taking their
behavioral cues from us
so let me leave you with this you know a
few years ago
it was really fashionable to say that
the internet was a revolutionary tool
that was going to bring us all together
it's now more fashionable to say that
the internet is a huge irredeemable
dumpster fire
neither caricature is really true right
we know the internet is just too vast
and complex to be all good or all bad
and the danger with these ways of
thinking whether it's the utopian view
that the internet will inevitably save
us
or the dystopian view that it will
inevitably destroy us
either way we're letting ourselves off
the hook
there is nothing inevitable about our
future
the internet is made of people people
make decisions
at social media companies people make
hashtags trend or not trend people make
societies progress
or regress when we internalize that fact
we can stop
waiting for some inevitable future to
arrive and actually get to work now
you know we've all been taught that the
ark of the moral universe is long but
that it bends toward justice
maybe maybe it will
but that has always been an aspiration
it is not a guarantee
the ark doesn't bend itself it's not
bent
inevitably by some mysterious force the
real truth
which is scarier and also more
liberating
is that we bend it thank you